foreign
[Music]
astragov no he's not a space-bearing
Metalhead he's a Mecca wearing magic
wielding limb petrified high priest of
her shut and he's on a mission to prove
his best sorcering days aren't yet
behind him
chaos dwarfs what a lovely pair of words
you'll be pleased to know our angry
little chaos friends have a nice variety
of ranged melee Cavalry and artillery
units as well as enough cannon fodder to
make the greenest of skaven's salivate
orc and Goblin laborers offer an
inexpensive front line that can be used
to distract your enemy's Army and
control the flow of the battlefield
we'll use them in our approach to soak
up arrows and conceal the units we
actually care about meanwhile astrogoff
and our Center boys are gonna loop
around the back and harass their arches
yep you heard that right extra gosh legs
are as Swift as they are utterly
terrifying
we've sent our blunderbusses to flank
the bulk of the Orcs And the result is a
similar consistency to mushy peas
all that's left now is for iron hand to
do his thing
[Music]
despite putting some green skins in
their place astrogoth is a far cry from
his former glory
a fact he'll need to overcome as he
consolidates the orc infested province
of Zorn as full to reclaim his rightful
place in the tower of zad
but proving he's the one true leader of
the conclave is an old iron hands only
goal oh no away into the domain of her
shut has shown itself and once breached
the chaos dwarfs can reap the most
potent power known to demon dowie kind
the blood of a shot to get there
astragov will need to build a drill a
very
very big drill which we can upgrade into
level 2 on level 4 at the cost of a
hefty sum of raw materials which means
we'll need a strong economy we'll return
to the great dwell of hashat in a little
bit but for now what better way to
amasgrave well and with great violence
the weekend were outnumbered and we're
on the offensive
thankfully the law of a shot with its
many fiery Boons comes in clutch burning
rappers are bread and butter in
Asperger's early campaign good damage
good range Good Vibes who doesn't like
swirling def lava
foreign
To the victor go the spoils another hard
one piece of the puzzle
unlike every other faction in the world
chaos dwarfs know the value of hard work
the work of a sweaty brow and calloused
Palms that's why chaos wolves don't
build any old settlements no no they
build outposts factories and Towers all
tools of the unrelenting machine of
Industry outposter need is a mind raw
materials factories turn those raw
materials into ornaments and gold and
towers are our sprawling Province
capitals but what do we build well
there's a lot of factors to take into
consideration and before we get there
let's rewind a little bit and take a
deeper look at our economy that's right
hold on to your seatbelt I said economy
chaos dwars are industrious little
fellas and that's reflected in the way
we'll manage our budding Empire's
resources Behold our new major
currencies treasury raw materials
ornaments and labor and then there's
conclave influence but we'll come back
to that later
treasury needs no explanation it's shiny
it's heavy we love it
raw materials does what it says on the
tin needed for certain buildings and
Technologies and can be converted into
ornaments or gold in specific Factory
buildings our primary source of raw
materials is from Outpost strip mines
but we can also trade with it using
military convoys which unlock at turn 5.
armaments primarily gained through
Factory assembly lines armaments are
used in the construction Advanced
military buildings and some technologies
as with raw materials we can trade
armaments on Military Convoy Expeditions
for other Goods
labor because all those tasty tasty
minerals aren't going to mine themselves
labor directly affects the output of our
raw materials while strip mines requires
more labor and a dwindling Workforce
produces fewer raw materials so keeping
your control in check is advised we can
perform various actions with our labor
force increasing our goal stores or our
conclave influence or we can move labor
around our sprawling Empire to bolster
provinces that might need the extra
Manpower you may have guessed it
laborers are largely unpaid gained from
willing battles and are usually green
skins so what to build we've established
that labor is important and its
Effectiveness is directly linked to a
promises control we need labor to mine
raw materials and those raw materials to
produce armaments and other Goods I've
got an idea and feel free to disagree
with me that's fine but I Envision a
chaos dwarf Empire with districts here
in my homeland I see the heart of my
mining Endeavors free outposts and
keeping all those laborers in line at
all terrible Tower
yeah let's do that our next Province
will be entirely factories and that'll
be our industrial district factories are
too important to sleep on though so
we'll build a mixture for now and
utilize the swap settlement feature when
it's District time
one of the handiest uses for labor is
instant construction for example we can
kick-start our economy by throwing
laborers at it instantly building a
money pit to get those coffers flowing
over in the tower we'll want to work
towards upgrading to rank two of the
Hefty cost of raw materials an upgraded
Tower will give us access to the lava
fills where we can churn out more
centaurs and the great tourists amongst
other handy benefits more ranks
eventually leads to the lanasu ball
Center renders and the dreaded Bell
Taurus but that'll take time and some
serious resources
before we move on it's a good idea to
get some technology Brewing but just
whilst the technology tree is split into
three branches military sorcery and
Industry no points for guessing which
one does well although our sorcery tree
is also where we'll find our diplomatic
Boons no wrong answers here we can cater
our society to fit very specific molds
military Powerhouse or economic Marvel
the choice is ours and we're going to
choose a nice mix spread we'll start
with Merchants Guild for the bonus to
trade and then we'll work towards envoys
of the conclave in the sorcery tree
which will get us on good standing with
our fellow chaos dwarfs it'll be a while
until we need to worry about unlocking
Technologies with specific resources so
let's just push that out of our heads
for now and whilst we're pushing that
out of our heads let's push some new
skills into astrogance
and we'll drop points into aspiring
presence now when fever and fodder later
I'm gonna be playing quite cannon fodder
heavy and it's nice if your meat Shields
don't run away at level 12 astrogoth can
unlock this lovely little Joy Master of
the conclave being quite so angry
expansive and repugnant the chaos dwarfs
get a fairly bad rap abroad anything we
can do to soften that image will be
handy in the long run
with our dashing ball sent our hero will
prioritize training where possible and
then just make him a Rikers stabber of
living things I reckon what a beautiful
bull man what's his name
zorak
I think not welcome to the party Natalie
almost done with turn one my word we'll
just recruit some sneaky gobbos another
unit of chaos dwarf Warriors and some
more Cannon fod I mean laborers then
it's all about the chaos dwarf Express
to murderville
choo choo yeah
dang green Skins are hold up on some
Prime real estate we'll spread our
attackers as is only correct and proper
to assault on four fronts
[Music]
frowned upon but I can take them
especially with a Little Help from the
laws of her shot and Fire
oh lava stomp you'd love to see it as
predicted astrogoth Natalie and there
sent our children made light work of
their orcish opponents elsewhere we're
making slow but steady progress into the
DIN and I can only imagine the Furious
indignation of the soon-to-be indentured
locals
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
with one entrance breached we're free to
sow chaotic Seas with our cavalry
[Music]
oh Mecca body slam
son is cool is once again United an
astrogoff's quest to re-establish his
dominance within the Tower of zark
we'll set the billowing Smoke Stacks
commandment to maintain control over our
labor and contemplate where to forge
ahead next remember we'll be looking for
a nice nearby Province to build our
factories
the path to the east is tempting and
opens us up to the mountains of mourn
though the ogres are not a force to be
taken lightly either way the saber Skins
are less than friendly war will sing in
the mountains eventually
tantalizingly close the high pass is our
most obvious choice and though these
crumbling ruins may appear abandoned
they hum with the scratching
machinations of skaven
there was not as immediate a threat the
vampires and the Orcs of the world Edge
Mountain hold no love for us and would
stand fast in the face of our expansive
ambitions
but not all our neighbors want us dead
and indeed our fellow chaos dwarfs also
call these lands home we would be wise
to foster a strong relationship of Our
Kind for in a world that hates our very
existence they are our truest hope for
an ally
just stomp on some rats
[Music]
app
foreign
[Music]
no matter what direction we started in
we're always going to end up in a
situation like this at least our Tower
will act as a barrier between the ogres
and the rest of our settlements he's got
a strong Garrison so we should be all
right for now if things start looking
hairy we can recruit an emergency Lord
and hope for the best
ah impulsive that's what I like my
leaders to be anyway we've only gone and
collected a fair few influence points
let's say we crack open the Tower of
Zara and see what's inside
okay all right I see how it is two seats
already taken
I guess that's what I get for savoring
my rat stomping
anyway much like the Castro's technology
pillows the tariffs are split into
industry military and sorcery there are
four tiers free districts and a whole
lot of Boons to gobble down with the
Ultimate Prize being the confederation
of our fellow chaos Dwarfs
to unlock the next tier two full
districts must be completed in the
previous tier thanks to my like-minded
kin we're well on our way to achieving
those ends not gonna lie I did want the
machinator seat for the bonus to raw
materials we could de-fron them we have
the influence to do so but we're still
trying to play nice at the moment so
probably not the best of ideas
I'm a little miffed but we'll park our
bum on the blacksmith seat for now extra
ornaments is nothing to sniff at and by
any means seats aren't permanent we'll
have another shot eventually
or we'll build an economy so vast of
receipt has dwarfed beneath our
all-encompassing buttocks ah politics
hmm unfortunately we're not quite secure
enough in our economy to easily swallow
the cost of sending a convoy out just
yet not whilst we're waging two Wars
anyway
you know what the Convoy will have to
wait back to squashing rats
foreign
I enjoyed that there's something
cathartic about watching skaven run for
their lives
right then the high pass is now our
industrial district we're not accepting
labor here instead funneling it all into
our mining District which we've now
converted into entirely outposts
I've opted not to build a tower in carag
flag I'll use them more on my Frontiers
to hold our borders firm much like our
Capital has been doing with the ogres
which is good because they're not
friendly thanks to the Tower of Zara and
our Master of the conclave talent we're
making diplomatic Headway with our
fellow chaos dwarfs and we may need to
call in some military favors soon if the
saber skins don't calm down anyway right
now we've got Greener fish to fry
the wells Edge mountains is home to the
red-eye Clan more green skins and
they're none too thrilled that we kick
their vampire friends out of the silver
pinnacle
they're gonna be less than filled when
we make them homeless
positively upset when we put them to the
mines whilst asrogoff psyches himself up
for more wholesome violence we'll have
our second Army begin the recruitment
drive for a pair of great Tauruses
taurusai
all right let's do this gearing up for
one big old war Bring It On ox
oh okay
there we go then 20 odd turns in and
we've managed to claw ourselves into a
somewhat steady footing the saber skin
ogres are still causing us a little
grief so we'll likely put them down next
but by adding the world's Edge mountains
to our growing territories we've opened
ourselves up to attacks from kisler
bites and our inferior Mountain dwelling
cousins indeed the journey ahead is
perilous and astrogoth's gonna need a
leg up if he I just mean you could use a
hand
I'm sorry
look what I'm trying to say is we've got
a new Epic Quest with some Stellar
rewards up for grabs the influence alone
will set us forward but the black hammer
of her shaft is a must for any
would-beam Master of the conclave
ah I think you burned in for keeping our
flying cows warm we'll put them to good
use worry not
[Music]
okay here's the deal we've got a derail
train and a very important payload to
deliver our task ensure the payload
arrives at the victory Point unscathed
grabby goblins and opportunist Orcs will
use this narrow Valley to their
advantage meaning we must be diligent
that's right kids it's an escort Quest
[Applause]
we've got a replacement train up and
running and I'd wager good money we'll
see our first Combat on one of these two
Bridges or both for good measure we'll
split our forces into two crack teams
with astrogoff heading one and later
lead the other
oh there they are we'll set our great
Taurus on their arches and take the rest
head on
as first waves go it's immensely
survivable bit of flanking bit of magic
bitter vigorous stabbing and they're
running for the Hills
as astrogos team continues to the next
ramp on the other side of the valley
Natalie's got a big old spider to squash
rather than me
[Music]
it's a tougher crowd than team may face
but nothing nasally can't handle
meanwhile more green Skins are pouring
into the valley and astrogoff's Keen to
meet them
[Music]
good job Natalie we'll take Team B to
the next round boss team a mops up the
stragglers
[Applause]
oh I think the great Taurus might be my
new favorite unit look at it go so
beautiful So Graceful so Moon
acceptance
oh right not too far from our
destination now and the payload's yet to
be scratched whatever comes next weekend
Oh the bars are coming in I should shut
up enjoy the film
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign